la cage était sur le bord de l'eau
bordelais de l'it de la rigole
complètement vide la cage était protégé
par le verrou cas devant aubry incarne
la can n'a été coupée et toutes les
menaces qui étaient autour des rigolos
ont toutes disparu
bruno a perdu entre 500 et 1000
grenouille ce jour là à n'en crée petit
village entre besançon et baume les
dames un individu aurait tout emporté un
connaisseur sans aucun doute
il faut aussi vous voyez des goulus
connaître la période dont classe été
volés dans la toujours un grand soir
comme on dit à la grenouille à un soir
on en voit plus que d'habitude elle est
là c'était notamment le grand soir je
pense parce qu'il ya eu un peu de pluie
dans la nuit dont quelqu'un qui connaît
bien bruno est un passionné rana
culteurs pour le loisir seulement mais
avec bientôt 20 ans d'expérience des
vols il en a déjà plusieurs fois fait
les frais alors là il avait prévu le
coup
donc la caméra était posée dans cette
zone là pour constater coup qu'elle soit
en vision directe avec la cage on avait
même faucher les réseaux sur ces images
on a un rôdeur qui passent trois dates
différentes qui fait du repérage avec
des jumelles qui s'intéressent à ma cage
de pompe ces images ont été remises à la
gendarmerie en charge de l'enquêté qui
devra par ailleurs déterminer les
motivations du mystérieux individu mais
ici ou les cuisses de grenouilles sont
la spécialité culinaire n'est pas
vraiment une
et ça ce rebond très très facilement les
grenouilles et
ça se vend généralement particulier en
particulier les gens pour chez ceux qui
veulent en mange à la maison voilà ces
quelques centaines
comme ça les grenouilles vivantes se
négocie autour des 50 centimes pièce en
y ajoutant le matériel volé bruno estime
son préjudice à 2000 euros